(audience cheering and applauding)
- We didn't wanna leave you out.
- Oh!
- You're welcome. Welcome to the show.
- Thank you. It's my
great pleasure to be here.
"The Meddler." Okay so-
- The what?
- We were in a movie together.
- I was gonna say, do
y'all know each other?
- We didn't have any scenes together.
- Oh, that's so- that bums me out.
I'd interview people all
the time, they're like,
"Well, yeah, we were
in the movie together,
but we never saw each
other." Like, that's sad.
- I love that movie.
- Yeah.
- It was a great movie.
And I just met Tom Brady
last night, for the first time.
- Oh really?
- He's in the movie, "80 for Brady," but
never met him while we were filming it,
but he's such a great guy.
- Wow.
- Yeah, oh my god, that last- yeah the-
I don't wanna spoil it
for anybody but yeah,
the scene where he's talking a little,
he's talking about the
end. I was, like, crying.
I was, like, "Wait,
why is Tom Brady making me cry right now?"
(audience laughing)
It happened. I was, like, "Okay,
he could pull some heartstrings."
How is your family doing?
- Ah, thank you for asking.
My family is on fire.
- They are?
- Yeah. My daughters,
my girls are, you know,
there they are. Okay so-
- It's a shame no one's
attractive in your family.
(audience laughing)
Oh my gosh.
- Well, I married the right
D-N-A. What can I say?
- You got "Sexiest Man Alive!"
I think you're doing alright. (laughs)
I love what you said.
(audience and Rose clapping)
Your wife, so she recently, um,
ended her run with "Real Housewives."
- She did.
- Were you excited about that.
- I am thrilled about
that. I get my wife back.
(Kelly laughing)
So for fans of that show,
sorry she's not gonna be there,
but I get her back.
(audience laughing)
- That's awesome. What's
your favorite reality show.
You watch reality TV?
- You know what? "Real Housewives."
- Really?
- "Of Beverly Hills," yeah.
That was the only one
I ever really got into.
It was so entertaining. Oh my goodness.
- Well, it's amazing, the
people who watch the show,
and who don't admit that
they watch the show.
- Oh!
- [Kelly] Oh really?
- I walk through the room,
and it's on with my wife,
and I see it, but no, they're all-
- I don't believe in guilty pleasure.
I just believe in pleasure.
I don't know why people always say-
- I agree.
- We just like it.
- You got that right.
Pleasure is pleasure.
- What's wrong with just liking it.
- And it's a character
study. You know what I mean?
When you can look at it like
that, like, it's behavior
of these people.
It's like, and I know a lot of it setup,
but how long has she done it for?
- She did it for 8 years. Now she's off.
And I have a degree in
psychology, and uh, I was able to-
- [Rose] Oh, what do you think?
- [Kelly] Do you really?
- I do, from Yale.
- What!
- I do.
(audience laughing)
- Cause you also wanted to be
an architect, I know. Right?
- Well originally, when
I left high school,
that's what I wanted to do.
But I got kinda sidetracked,
uh, by a hell's angel
in some tree houses, in
La Honda, California.
- Did Snoop give you a blunt too?
(audience laughing)
- It was more than a blunt.
(Rose and Kelly laughing)
Anyway, I got sidetracked
and I missed my registration
to the architecture school.
I only had 45 minutes to register,
I was going to have to wait a
whole quarter to re-register
and the guy at the
architecture school said,
"You know the drama department
is right over there,
and if you run over there
now, fill out the forms,
you might be able to get
it in under the wire."
- That worked out.
- Yeah, how about that.
I never looked back.
- I love the love of
architecture. I do too.
I think it's so interesting
how people's minds work and-
- And I still am into
it, I love architecture.
I built a house, and I also
built a couple retail stores,
so I got a little bit
of it out of my blood.
- Well, how about the psychology
degree, did that work out?
How are you using that? (laughs)
- Well I use that to help
Lisa get through that show.
(Rose and audience laughing)
- What would you do if you weren't acting?
What do you think you would have done?
- I would've done, like,
teaching or something.
Like a total acting- cliche.
I started so young, yeah I think teaching.
I probably would've ended up
doing something like that.
- That means you can be patient.
- Well, yeah, I'm not bad.
I'm not bad until I snap.
And then I'm- (laughs)
- We're all not bad until we snap.
- Exactly. I don't think I'm
any exception to that rule.
But I think, yeah. What about you Kelly?
- Not a teacher. Like,
no, my mom was a teacher
and those people are angels. I could never
ever do that. Like, it just takes so-
there's so many kids in one spot,
and you're wrangling them,
and they all learn differently
at different paces. That is
an incredibly difficult job.
- Yeah.
- I don't think I would've set
myself up for that, mentally.
- But they're all heroes.
- They're heroes, yeah,
absolutely. My mom's an incredible,
like, teacher.
I love them. I lift them up
all the time on this show,
but I could never. I would never-
- What do you think you would've done?
- I don't know. Like, I was
a really solid waitress,
I will be honest with you.
(Rose and audience laughing)
I know we're all in the business-
- Chuck E. Cheese.
- I would've nailed that
doll at Chuck E. Cheese, man.
No, I don't know. I don't
really have any- I don't know.
There was no other option
other than singing.
- I get it.
- But you're in the new
movie, "80 for Brady".
Love the movie.
You play a legendary N-F-L
player, but you're in this movie,
also, with these iconic women. Like,
what was that like, being on set?
Because we had them all here
and they are a handful in the best way.
- I mean, how lucky was I,
to be working with those-
How lucky was I to kiss Jane
Fonda, in a broom closet?
- It's like every- In a broom
closet's my favorite part.
(Harry and audience laughing)
And it was amazing how you got caught.
No, but, how was it on set?
I just feel like it was probably
a fun set, with everyone.
- It was a really fun set,
but really professional also.
I mean, this is like,
these women are like
very very fine-aged wine.
And working with them was
unbelievably great, I mean,
and Jane Fonda, she loves to run lines.
Which I like to do, too, as a
professional actor, but Rita-
- What does that mean, when
you're saying running lines?
You mean like just-
- Running lines is when
you, before your scene,
you rehearse the scene before you go on.
- Do people not do that?
- A lot of people don't do
that. Yeah, a lot of people-
- I didn't do that with Snoop.
- You didn't do that with Snoop?
He was like, "Let's
just wing it." (laughs)
- Laid back.
- I didn't know that. I didn't
know people didn't, like,
rehearse. That seems
like a- not a good idea.
- It is not a good idea, that's
why professionals do that,
and one day Rita, um, you know,
Moreno, who's 91 by the way,
and a firecracker.
- And does not appear 91.
- Not at all. Not at all.
So there was a big scene
that she had coming up, but I thought-
I asked her if she wanted
to run lines, you know,
and rehearse the scene and
she said, "Sure, let's do it."
So I'm reading off of the script,
and I'm stumbling over the words,
and she has it like, (finger
snapping) 91 years old.
Not one single stumble all the way down.
- I don't know she's doing, yeah-
- Whatever she's doing, we gotta do it.
- Yeah, can we get that info?
- It was not normal.
We all talked about it
when they all left. I was like,
"Can we talk about how
she's supposed to be 91,
like, and that' a lie?"
(Harry and Rose laughing)
It's like, there's no
way. Anyway, how was it
playing like an N-F-L
legend, that whole character?
Was that kind of fun?
- It was a blast to play but, you know,
(stammers)
I'm an actor, look, these
guys are giants, you know,
these football players. They're
all like seven feet tall.
I'm a normal human. I'm a mortal
(Kelly and Rose laughing)
- I'm one of the mortals, not the gods.
- They gave me these two huge
Super Bowl rings to wear,
and they had to wrap the
inside of them with tape
because they would fall off
of my tine hands, you know.
(audience laughing)
I mean, these guys are gigantic.
- Big dudes, yeah.
- They're big, I mean, I
met Tom last night, Brady,
and yeah... yeah.
"Hey Tom, how are you? Nice
to meet you." (chuckles)
- That's a good one to
meet, he's the goat, yup.
Well, everybody, you
can see "80 for Brady"
in theaters right now, and
you can also watch Harry in
"Mayfair Witches" on A-M-C.
Be sure to check that out as well.